on vous inscrire au vider vos greniers
sur internet rendez vous sur www.rtbf.be
sport et cliquez sur le cas raymond
espace personnel puis à gauche
cliquez sur créer mon espace compléter
le formulaire étape par étape en ré
saignant votre identité puis autre
adresse
et enfin votre adresse mail
[Musique]
choisissez votre nom d'utilisateur et
votre mot de passe qui doit comprendre
au moins huit caractères dont une
majuscule et un chiffre saisissez le
code de sécurité puis validez confirmé
la création de votre espace en cliquant
sur le lien envoyer à l'adresse mail
indiquée
vous pouvez maintenant déclarer votre
toit ge étape indispensable
seuls les champs obligatoires doivent
être impérativement rempli ce qui
concerne votre adresse postale
n'oubliez pas de valider cet état crée
maintenant votre inscription en cliquant
sur le pavé bleus commençaient
télécharger un justificatif de domicile
de moins de trois mois
en sélectionnant la mine puis votre
pièce d'identité
si vous avez une demande particulière
c'est dans la case observations qu'il
faut la formule et consulter le
règlement et cochez les cases
obligatoire aller à l'étape suivante
puis validez
[Musique]
pour recevez un mail de confirmation
avant d'accéder au calendrier les
services communication et événementiel
vérifie que des pièces fournies sont
bannis et que votre inscription est
complet cette étape peut demander un
délai maximum de deux jours ouvrés une
fois l'inscription validé par le service
vous recevez une notification par mail
dans la page d'accueil de votre espace
personnel
cliquez sur le bloc modifier les
réservations puis sur la ligne qui
s'affiche
videz vos greniers vous accédez alors au
calendrier de réservations
il ne vous reste plus qu'à choisir votre
date de participation 25 joueurs et au
24 septembre pour demander un
emplacement de s'y mettre
cochez les deux cases trois mètres et 15
16 euros bonne idée
vous accédez alors au service de
paiement sécurisé en entrée votre numéro
de carte bleue la date de validité et le
cryptogramme visuel qui se trouve au dos
de la carte de paiement
vous recevez un mail de débit et vous
pouvez télécharger votre facture
[Musique]
votre inscription a bien été enregistré
et vous recevrez votre numéro
d'emplacement par mail ou courrier
courant juin
[Musique]